le maquereau a gagné la présidentielle
avec une association pas un parti c'est
quand même inédit
il faut quand même le rappeler mais ils
ont fait émerger à l'assemblée
énormément de nouveaux visages
l'assemblée quand même plus proche de la
france réelle qu'elle ne l'était jusque
là on s'est même beaucoup moqué dans les
médias ou autres de la maladresse du
caractére ingénue naïve de ses militants
qui précisément être des débutants dont
on ne connaissait pas tous les codes et
c'était plutôt je dirais réjouissant de
manière ça correspondait aussi à ce
qu'on espérait autrefois un petit peu
avant et donc il ya quand même déjà cet
apport la qui est à mettre au bénéfice
cette nouvelle organisation qui
maintenant rentrer dans le dur qui est
d'arriver j'imagine ça va être grand
rendez-vous dans marche maintenant avoir
des élus aux élections européennes aux
élections locales parce que c'est ça qui
est important sinon ça n'existe pas
important de se banaliser d'avoir des
élus vous allez partout sur le
territoire pour être des réseaux des
relais des points d'appui des points
d'inspiration mais s'il ya pas une image
fr juste site se dégonfler de je
plussoie que les 350 mille adhérents
phase aller on est pas c'est un clic
parce qu'à l'avenir tous les
journalistes qui sont impliqués pour
essayer les informations et d'ailleurs
je trouve qu'on devrait le dire ça j'ai
peur que ça passe à projets mais du coup
et ça peut pas dégonflé aussi vite que
ses montées si si c'est possible bien
sûr c'est tellement fragile et puis ça
arrive un moment où c'est encore une
fois c'est phénoménal de voir il n'y a
pas un pays aujourd'hui démocratique qui
n'est pas confronté à la crise des
organisations politiques ces grandes
démocraties petite démocratie parti
dominant mes petits devenus petits
moyens partie regarder en allemagne et
partout en autriche
il n'y a pas un des noyaux muni ils ont
l'air d'avoir retrouvé de leur force
mais n'arrive même pas à gouverner à
faire des majorités il faut acheter des
députés pour avoir des majorités c'est
vraiment ce qui s'est passé au royaume
uni donc c'est vraiment un phénomène
très passionnant et historique fin d'un
cycle qui a commencé à la fin du 19e
siècle en marche
il ya une forme de renouveau ça a été
dit maintenant il ont pas encore trouvé
je suis pas sûr qu'ils arrivent à les
trouver